緊張するなぁ
入っちゃったことないんですよ裏とない
ですね
すごいどうすごいですか
オーラというかも
すごい
地獄がいい夜の20日幼虫8分後13時に
なろうとしております
大門というかその伝説級方いうツーラーも
芸能人含めた3社長の3兄の家に泊まるの
初のことです大
いらっしゃいませんだねもらってました
ああああああ
ございますはい
山名
ありません
平成の流れています
ある曲の歌詞はありません運営
[音楽]
今日もいけるんですねただの落ちちゃうん
だよいやいやいやいやを一つ目ですよ中で
お写真目指しいやー本当に遅ございました
いい
とんでもねえけども
とりあえず
遅くなりましたが1000万におめでとう
ありがとうございますオーディオも
いただいてあと
3億円の工程を彦署名とかありがとう
ございま
それを言いたくて来ました本当ですか
ございでございますぜひ皆さん聞いて
ください
衝撃的なことに
今晩何とあの山田孝之さんが家にと破って
いかれますございます
以上しますー
インでき買うよこちらこそですよ前回なぁ
のホラー質問コーナーやったとあぁそうで
すごいこのたら気になったじゃないですか
前回のお話をむきごとに僕月
さんってこんなことまでやってくれるん
ですか
全然あのこれぐらいは
あれねもう汚れた状態でしゃーかつて
もらえたじゃないですかあそで手打ち誤差
は
それがあったんで
昭和化してくれるっていうなぁもしかしは
とまらしてくるんじゃないかなーっ
ちょっと言ってみたかったんですね山田さ
んって結構人のお家と回られる方です
ちょっちょっと丸わけじゃないけどねあり
ますよまあそうだねそうね引越したばっか
で何もないところを見たことあるよね
ほんと持っどこでも出るんですよ絶対ここ
で寝たいみたいなの全然を枕持った
し床でになりますそんなこと絶対させない
ですぜひ1番楽しい言ってくださいはい
子ちゃんそこでやれずよ
あみあみ旅
[音楽]
2をこれを点がの講師これでが硬水です皆
さんもしておりますあっはや回転スイッチ
思います調節できる良くなればぜひどっち
かわかんないけど地方3かねこれ
さあ高知でコゼットを避けませんにもやを
しているそうかありがとうございました
あの羽田から品川駅持ってたんであっ周目
も買っていますよまーすげぇー
んん
山田さんから頂くポインターが高そうじゃ
ないんですよそんなことないよこれだった
んですかねん
em めちゃめちゃたかそうじゃない
サマーあのも白酒はあ
ただもあるからあるている知ってもらう
けどなく常にやスタッフと
じゃじゃあもぜひのますいただきます
良ければ軟骨乾杯してもいいんですけど
本当ですかきます a したいですしたい
ですよねいや大丈夫なっちゃったもんだ
言って
今日で落とさずやります止めちゃダメ受け
て開けていいねぇか
失礼します
ミョンエマってよはさんと鮭ダメ例が来る
だって
なかったん
[音楽]
仕掛けないようなに馬術かわいいよおお
ありません動いていません
かしこまりましたもう
すごい枝なった流して入っ
1000万人と
引っ越しおめでとうございますありがとう
ございまーすバイバイ
[音楽]
飲み方い
これめっちゃ組みやすい美味しいねーな
よかったと
を刺激ラティスが置くときトントン
ドドスコよしこいそういうのははい国と
ほとんどじゃないとか俺もだいっぱいです
頑張ってきた甲斐があったいやありがとう
ございます遠くから桜
ずん能力よ
歩い用上下すーっwh ん
me
止め c 本当にこれでイヤーこちらこそ
いつも次来ていただける機会があったら
本当に沈み整えさせていただければ別だ俺
はさっきも言ったように床でも出るした
から絶対こんなことか変よそれをやっぱ気
になってるのは壁ですよ俺もちょっと
寂しいだなーって
コンクリートですからねぇアート買ったり
するんですよおっそうなんですかするんだ
けどほとんどがもう無名な人ばっかり ai
でもいいのありまして本当に全然
フォロワーとかもそれにしたと思えば
アーティスト今あげるんですよそこで知っ
てもらいたいからフォロワーでももっと
数百人とかしかいない人もいる
そのすごい
小麦だからそうですねいいのありました
いいなあそれ
c つい頬ピカソ見た目みたいな普通で
動くとかやってるんですか多分はダウンと
思ってほしいんでしょするんじゃない
山田さんとの酒運営なぁ
いつも a やっを中盤肇社長
旅パ
[音楽]
ティ e じゃないっむしろ
先のんで初めて仲良くなれる人かいません
自由も俺の中につもりたんだけどねここだ
か良いと思いですけどもっと深くというか
もうちょっとねだから外れるからね素地
そうですねそうそれこそ卒中1を聞きたい
ことがん団体をぜひぜひ
なんかやばい初でっついてくださいぜひ
外れるわけじゃないけどこれでいいんだ
けどはっはっはまださんが何かあって
うわーってなる人ってどんな人ですこれ
あってすごい嬉しかった人は嬉しかった
嬉しかっといっぱいいるけどなぁ
[音楽]
朝のさ水戸どうでしょうね赤さんはされた
とかすごいですよ男性だと思う
[音楽]
マイケルシャツマイケルザクとすごいやね
凄い凄いなぁくらいあるかというかねまぁ
本当の時空館に立ってるんです良いですよ
でもししたとかでもあると言いますよ
ポスト
8ぐらいオーナー19と今ちょうど10個
したら着2
今97今年9は中国とかって
やっぱね菅田将暉+釜崎とすごいはれます
おいてはね氏はその
陣屋だ
だからわざとも言えないかと
なんでございますいやだから今日はから
うまいねそう引っ越しを祝えと登録者数の
迫りのお祝いできたでながらここに進み
始めてしばらく買ったから何かできること
はないかと
なるほどそう
だからだとへ補足今日友達とはがね明日と
かこれでできることであればてツアーして
もらいたいなと思ってるんですよまあ静か
には
ギバーモックさあとか工房だった触れあり
ましょう
ずキレイにしましょうだぞこれは断捨離も
あるけどさちょっとキレイに整えると
気持ちが良くなってましたそうですね自分
気持ちを込めてきれいにしたりとかしても
大事であっ
山田さんついていいですか行かなきゃダメ
でしょ
恒賀山するとかねはい月ライフ急げ急げ
日本の参考と東京でさせいきましょう
a 管いて出さないです
キャビンで結構そんながちな感じん
[音楽]
ブーバーそれは
ティロさ教えたっ連れてきたまあ白さ操作
てアップ遊びたこのそうですねますらが
大目に見てあげです
中古言わないけど
心の奥底デー
やっぱ近くに落ちちゃうとベルジャンし
たくなると思います
人たち
祝といつもがんばって
おやすみ
う時間見つけて
年か
大事な時間を削ってきてるのに
[音楽]
やっぱそういう大学生のちょっとした話と
かで
幸せの時間が奪われてるんだって思うと
で防いだりしてくれよ
そういうパターンの良い硬さだロックは
どうでもいいですよそのさらにいる人を
しゃべったりとかいいですけど
限られた時間の中でサラダを楽しんでる人
が
いや直井するドア
これはゆる時代です絶対
[音楽]
1回で城内きている自分からそういう
ところで苦しい音がしたくないから自分
から言ったけどそうでめちゃくちゃないと
あれだぞ
素晴らしいから2分近所でし記事っていう
理由だけだんだんだがぜか野菜
バッテリ r かー
ていません
いざマネー
神崎でもコーチからを得られればなんとの
ば先が一番前今まで飲んだ酒で一番前に
日の目先にちょっとねえぞ内でももっと干
鮭バルマー氏図鑑後手術にそういうこと
じゃのお酒の種類とかじゃなくて
ヶ月かいい
金な贅沢な空間がへ
今度山田その at 築くためか
ですよ前だけど俺だけあのメイク俺だけは
なに帰るよ行かれる俺は気あるとき先生が
桁目の訪問です新銀
3ネスチャーとりあえず
でもしかあげましょう
そうですね
支えられません
シャワーってはもうぜひできるいっ
し注意し兄がいなくにあって俺は山中で
そのベッドでツってありますか
ですねー
ああああああああ
持ってしまおう
やばいぞやばいゼロにするッ
作戦似合うなぁお山で場所一緒に入って
ねーよかっ話し合った
[音楽]
風邪引かなかったけパリアなってよ
じゃあ電気がしてねそうですねだおやす
みっ
[音楽]